you know I found weird recently now that
like I guess the country's opening back
up and we've complained for so many
backups oh well opening back up by the
time this episode's out it should be it
should be kind of completely open where
you don't even need to go on like one of
the North Korean tour guides
um you don't need a covert test
um and you can just come I'm not sure if
it'll be open for tourists by the time
this comes up but right now more people
that we know are coming in the country
yeah like recently we've obviously had
the safety third crew come on as you
know we've had a a few of their members
on our podcast uh Kevin's finally been
gonna be able to come back as well yeah
but he but he arrives like what is like
two days before we all have to leave
exactly and I saw like a few more people
on Twitter that said oh finally you know
just landed in Japan or coming to Japan
I'm like this is so [ __ ] weird we've
complained about this so long and now
people are actually coming in and now
I'm just like damn I don't really I
don't really have the time to show
people around
yeah and then they get here and I'm like
actually you know gone is making me
record this trash taste
why is coffee
he's a leader but like man's throwing
you under the bus
I've just been blaming trash teeth
because I'm like well it's it's like the
boys you know I gotta prioritize work
sorry guys you know it's Alpha that's
the greatest that's the great thing
about trash taste because if if it was
just like your own channel then it's on
you you know you choose your own
schedule we're trash teeth we got a team
I don't want to let the boys down you
know and they're like why don't you want
the rest of the boys I'm like oh you
know they're busy as well yeah I don't
want to ask them back to shooting you
know yeah but uh yeah took the uh safety
third people out last weekend and do you
know what I've realized
um after people have started coming in
where you're not gonna you're not gonna
experience this Joey because you already
are you already can speak Japanese but
because people are starting to come in
they everyone assumes that you're only
hunger Josie now because you've lived
here no but I I mean I you speak a
little bit that sounds like
are you doing a lot of speaking for I
can't remember it was I think a lot of
asking a bunch of questions when Emily
first came here as well I was talking a
lot for her yeah and on the first few
days and yeah she's like she's like well
you're so good at this I'm like no no
I say one thing yeah I'm guessing like I
I because I'm having like conversations
but obviously any conversation at all
when you don't speak the language seems
like nuts yeah yeah but when you're you
know when you when you're with someone
who understands it you're like bro why
are you doing like a two-year-old so
what you're telling me is that it was
the first time you actually felt like
you had to be the token translator yeah
yeah because because it was the first
time
you for the menus that are handwritten
can't you yeah but like the problem is
Joey I'm nowhere near even close to your
level but people are assuming that I am
your level so people so people people
like hanging out with them obviously
like first thing you do you go to the
taxi you tell them where to go and
people are like yo what the [ __ ] your
Japanese is so good and I'm like I
literally just said please stop here sir
just said hey here is okay please stop
here yeah and and then they get like a
lot of people ask me oh how do you say
this in Japanese how'd you say that in
Japanese and like some of the things I
do know but I know for a fact that there
there is like a Japanese way to say it
and I'm doing like the most Brute Force
direct translation I can think of of my
like baby Japanese yeah do you know what
it is though that I have found it's it's
not about like whether you have like an
extensive vocab or anything like that
it's I feel like confidence oh yeah it
goes such a long way no because like if
you confidently without like even a
shadow of a doubt walk up to a Japanese
person and just start speaking in the
most broken ass Japanese ever like oh me
hungry food like but if you say it with
absolute confidence like like a game
face and people see that they're just
like damn
yeah I had that happen yeah yeah that
was not good but it but it's bad right
because like sure it might look cool to
your Foreigner friends who don't know a
word of Japanese but then that Japanese
person will probably also feel the same
way being like Oh damn this guy's good
at Japanese I'm just going to start
speaking at a normal pace and then the
moment they reciprocate to that you're
just like I'm like you know like because
being living in Japan you have certain
scripts for certain places yeah you've
heard it a million times it's like
playing a visual novel I wouldn't know
how that feels but I'm actually just
like you've played like a million times
you know all the dialogue options and
The Roots yeah exactly that's kind of
like learning languages in general you
know that's that's it's just picking up
patterns yeah you pick up patterns
um and if something goes out of that
pattern then you're kind of like a dear
panic because here's the thing right
normally you know when you're by
yourself you know sometimes you're just
not in the mood to go challenge yourself
to go out of your comfort zone or
something but when you're showing people
around Japan you got that pressure on of
course because I look around I'm like
surely there's someone morning hunger
Jersey than me no [ __ ] I'm the hunger
Josie guy here [ __ ] it's me that's gonna
sort everything out okay I think it's
also worse when you're the one who like
reluctantly is like yeah I'll show you
guys around right and so you're already
exuding that like yeah yeah
and then when you're actually in the
spot you're like [ __ ] I have to show
them around
I don't know what to do so oh so one
thing they were all looking for a place
to eat so um
where did you take them uh I took them
to an or you can eat uh Yakiniku place
okay yeah yeah because what I realized I
asked Malin where I should take them and
she gave me a bunch of like
recommendations Michelin star plays and
I was just like I don't think this would
be suitable for a group of like 12. yeah
right everything becomes like 500 times
harder when you have more than six
people in Japan yeah oh easily yeah
you either have to go an all-you-can-eat
place or an easy Kyle yeah it's like no
other choice yeah and I was just like
life hack you were showing someone
around Japan they've never been to Japan
before they've been here once go to an
all-you-can-eat place and that will
impress them yeah you know just it's so
it's so easy yeah
Japanese hot pot or you can eat and
that's like it's insane I've never even
been there before have you not no bro
it's so good there's like a there's like
a billion of them in Shinjuku yeah I was
impressed dude it's nuts it's like 40
bucks no it's not even 40 bucks 44 000
yen to like 30 something bucks yeah you
can and then you get all you can eat as
much food as you want and then all you
want or you can drink for two hours it's
like eight dollars or something or like
ten bucks
it's actually just like what are we
doing exactly that's that's how are
these places making money I I I I that's
because they don't know that's because
they don't you know they're not used to
foreigners I think because the the big
thing sound do music no exactly because
the big thing I've noticed especially
after taking more people out too all you
can eat places is that when Japanese
people here all you can eat it's all you
want to eat when you hear like an
America when you change it to all you
can eat yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah when
you take an American or a British person
or most people in the west to an all you
can eat place it is a challenge right it
is not a all you want or you're
comfortable to eat it is how much can my
stomach expand before like how how
quickly can I bankrupt this place to
make them feel like they made them the
biggest mistake of that life to make
something called all you can eat that is
true actually like I've been to enough
Buffets in Vegas now to know that like
seeing like seeing Americans in a buffet
is like you think like the apocalypse is
coming where they're just like I was
like are you about to fast for three
days like why are you eating so much I
don't even enjoy it like yeah I just I
get to a point where I'm like full and
I'll just push like 30 beyond that yeah
just because I'm like well
I may as well and it's like but yeah no
other situation would I ever order this
much for you no I would I would have cut
it off like years ago yeah so so like we
went to this all week in a yakaniki
place and immediately we sit we sit down
and I haven't haven't like had this
mindset in a while but immediately they
start asking me questions right because
they start asking me what the rules of
the game are you know like okay
hypothetically if we over order by
hypothetically hypothetically speaking
if we over order by four plates of food
will they charge us for it and I'm like
I I don't I don't really know because
that's never really happens but I mean
I'm sure you could play The Foreigner
card and so they're like great that's
all we need to know they order like a
[ __ ] ton of food and like here's the
thing normally this all you can eat
Yakiniku plays they have like it's like
real coals right so normally uh this
restaurant have placed enough coals in
this barbecue to last you for about the
two hours right normally it's it's like
perfectly timed so you have enough time
to eat the food and then by the time the
two hour ends the calls we kind of died
out well that'll be fine because you're
like you'll be like oh I'll take like
one more plate or something like that
yeah
not not with these guys so we we get to
like an hour and a half in and the
waiter comes over and it's just like oh
last order's in about like five ten
minutes would you like to order anything
else
um
with like it was like me Sydney uh
Liberty who's a Content producer you
know that there's like you know the more
Japanese Centric table that have that
you have that common sense with the
culture and then there's the boys on the
other side the safety third boys they
hear the last orders coming in and
they're they're like um can we order
like 10 more plates and also can we
change the coals and I think it would it
wasn't ordering the 10 more plates yeah
it was the request to change the calls
right right because like I don't think
in the history of this establishment
anyone's asked to change the calls 30
minutes before last orders are coming in
the wages like what you you want me to
you want me to change the calls what
what I I don't understand why don't you
why do you want to change the calls and
so there's there's us there's us the
Japanese residence on one side just
being like I'm so full I'm so full and
then there's the American boys on the
other side 15 minutes in and they're
getting like 10 more plates to meet I'm
like how the F how are you doing this
what [ __ ] so did they did they even like
put a dent in that or they [ __ ]
finished it they it like like I said it
was a challenge it wasn't like it was it
was they wanted to make a statement
right they wanted to make a statement
that this establishment was a [ __ ]
idiot right
they love breaking news yeah yeah
they're like if I'm not bankrupting this
place then uh then I've done something
wrong no wonder all you can eat places
don't [ __ ] last in the US yeah I feel
like that's a mindset thing that we get
like born into like I I the first time I
went to all you can eat in Japan I I
know you can drink I'm like I gotta I
gotta I gotta tell you I'm taking this
I'm taking the weights off yeah I'm
going in yeah and I don't know why like
why do I immediately hear a reasonably
priced buffet and I'm like instead of
making this into a normal meal where I'm
probably gonna get my money's worth
anyway I'm just gonna try and ruin
myself and ruin this right weird
psychology isn't it because it's like
there's no pressure it's not like you're
losing money yeah I think also like a
big thing is just when you're obviously
they're traveling around when you're
just in Holiday mode oh the rules
uh you know holiday mode the rules are
off you know you're not trying to look
after you I'm sure it'll be the opposite
if we went to the US yo actually there's
Buffets in Vegas look insane
yeah they're like like Gourmet buffets
or something yeah only America would
they want to bastardize food there man
so like let's do it yeah like when we
went to LA I went to so many [ __ ] all
you can eat Korean barbecues because
that's the one [ __ ] thing one [ __ ]
thing I miss about La which is the
Korean barbecue there is amazing
um and I you know like luckily or
unluckily the rules are a bit more
strict there because they have a bit
more people who are let's say over order
so they're like you have to you'd have
to have those rules yeah if you if you
they're like if you order like one play
over we're gonna charge you I've noticed
that actually not a lot of Japanese I
think I've been to like maybe one place
where they like charge you if you don't
finish your food that you order extra
off but like for the most part yeah I
think Japanese people are more sensible
and being like I'll order what I can eat
yeah a lot of places well we'll probably
just like if you have like one plate
left over they're like ah all right yeah
all right but obviously you know I'm
just thinking like I'm just thinking of
the situation that both that rule yeah
you know like what what what person went
to like an all-you-can-eat Korean
barbecue it's just like oh yeah so you
kind of just left like 40 kilograms of
meat
balls they're just like go kill the cow
give me a whole cow I went to a Yakiniku
place with Chris and saitama yeah right
and I remember like it's normally right
obviously Jackie niku writes poles and
stuff says a lot of smoke yes yeah um we
go there at like five o'clock it just
opened middle of nowhere inside time
legit middle of nowhere right um and we
go in and it's a pretty big restaurant
for a bit where what I thought was big
ration of where it was so we walk in
and the staff are immediately like whoa
foreign
cook the food yeah and I noticed that
like the fan isn't on to like suck out
all the the smoke yeah yeah and so I'm
like I'm like oh I'm like should we ask
him Chris to turn it on it's like it's
kind of a lot of smoke yeah and the guy
comes over and we're like hey um could
you could you could you turn the fan on
and he's like yeah of course just walks
away
and then and then I it starts to kind of
build up yeah and I suddenly look around
the corner and there's just smoke
everywhere in this building okay right
and I'm like when are they gonna come
come over and turn the fan on I don't
know how to turn the fan on it was like
a really old Antiquated fan and then
eventually they're like oh did you turn
the fan off we're like no they're like
why is it off like it was never on I
just thought I'd put the blame on you
and mastered it did we turn it off and
we were like no no no no no they seem
like sus about it and they were like
never again foreigners never again right
all [ __ ] foreigners
they were literally just smoking out the
place and they took like [ __ ] 20
minutes to realize and I just felt
really bad and I was like why why did
this happen this is why phone is online
it wasn't like an old building or like
an old yeah it's pretty old
um no I mean yeah dude I did that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up and did that thing by the way
with the confidence Japanese thing got
it wrong yeah not really I feel like you
need to though oh yeah dude I well no I
did it the other day oh um because I was
we just had like trash taste I was tired
and we went to the place uh like this
Izakaya with uh 73rd people yeah a bunch
of other people and they were like oh
well how many oysters is it on the
picture and there's there's a picture
and it's like a bunch of oysters like
six of them in one plate and it was like
600 Yen and I was like oh
um I was like I don't know I don't think
it's 600 Yen for six oysters that's
pretty cheap especially in this kind of
restaurant yeah yeah oh yeah don't worry
I'll ask them
woman comes over I'm like oh swimmers
which is uh how long
oh yeah how long are the oysters yeah
yeah and she was like what but I was
super confident about it like confidence
100. and then she just told me
and then she went
she looking like she literally went like
what and then when
I was like oh okay well I got my answer
and I was like I was like did I did I
did it was like 600 Yen for one um
she was like mental arithmetics
yesterday like yeah and so I was like
guys it's it's 600 Yen for an oyster and
they're like oh you're amazing wow